mom people in the chat have questions
for you
can i ask you them
no
yeah just while we're waiting i'll turn
it off when we go to dinner
um
hi
hi guys my mom's here today
this is
the birther of
seven kids
mother of ten you know
making french fries like it
mom have you always cooked
has dad ever cooked
has he ever done laundry
has he ever
yeah
cleaned
when kids puked he was always the
cleaner
oh yeah he does
the puke cleaner ever
and the diaper blow out of the [ __ ] oh
wait what
i said when there was a diaper yeah he
was always on that one too
he did the really shitty jobs they say i
look just like you i think i'm like a
perfect mix of my parents um because
whenever anyone sees either of them they
say i look like them
um
mom if someone flew you out to france
would you go
for vacation i really want to go to
paris no mom it means like like you
exchange your body for the flight
um oh no
[Laughter]
um
do they go on 50
no probably not
are you 50 i think you're 40 something
i'm 50 i turned 50 last year
oh are you really i think you're 49. i'm
almost 51.
um i just round up and start saying 51.
yes
my parents own a software company owned
their sal they sold it
he's almost 40.
let me know
[Music]
okay for dinner tonight we're having
french fries that's our dog sweet potato
fries oh shoot you want to show us what
we're having mom
i did sweet potato fries and potatoes
from our garden
you have
garden a potato that we're having uh
and
a
carrots from our garden tonight too oh
we needed a new carrot recipe we'll see
how that turns out
that's garlic honey carrots
not sure about that one
there may not be good and then we have
um
farm fresh um
burgers that i forgot to buy buns for so
on bread
oh actually mom i have a question do you
think that women are worse today than in
your generation
okay do you think that women are worse
today and are in our generation than
your generation or do you think social
media just shows it um i think women
i just spent a bunch of time
interviewing a certain young woman and i
would say that i think they're mostly a
bunch of bored
[Music]
a there's two people no because every
man wants to have sex every single day
of every single minute of every single
flight
women are 100 in control so why would
you just give that away
well because men like each other well i
think it's because there's girls like
there's girls that have made like a
career out of that
yeah i think that's why like you know
like kim kardashian like
she like horde around in her 20s and
then ended up with like kanye
like i think she started further up the
food chain too so
yeah no i know i'm not saying it's like
realistic
women are in 100 control so why would
you give that up you guys can you guys
hear my mom someone says i can't hear
her
there are some men that like each
other's buttholes well hey stop talking
like that
i don't care do you get nervous for
yourself oh actually austin's picked a
good one greg picked a guy i was gonna
say like about finding wives
it's really gone downhill in the last
five years i think
do you feel like your son is part of the
problem
[Laughter]
adam's a lady killer
i've never killed anything that's the
truth
but he is such a beautiful boy there's
no reason for him to be selling himself
out
to all these little [ __ ] but he found
he found um
[Laughter]
okay
[Applause]
wow
i
i was not expecting that i really wasn't
um
you know
[Music]
i know
um
[Laughter]
okay guys we're about to eat i'm going
to show you the table
um
that's amelia okay we got i'm going to
give them a tour
that's what is this carrot why don't you
give them a tour
um okay
homemade garlic honey carrots that were
oven-baked
home-grown potatoes and sweet potato
fries
um farm fresh burgers with cheddar
cheese
portobello muffins
and then bread because i forgot to buy
them
i can't believe she forgot the buns oh
my gosh
we lose control
okay ready in the name of the father of
the son the holy spirit amen god is
great god is good and we thank him for
our food by his hand we are fed we thank
him for our daily bread i don't want
them back
all right guys
i know i'm gonna end it all right guys
i don't know how i'll manage but somehow
i'll eat the bun burgers i'll do it
okay bye
how do i end it